-And after three weeks
of humiliating chaos,
Republicans finally elected
a speaker of the House
who isn't just a far-right
election denier,
but was actually one of
the architects of the effort
to overturn
the 2020 election results.
The House GOP's decision
comes as Trump himself faces
damning new legal developments
in three separate cases
across the country,
from Michael Cohen's
testimony in New York
to Mark Meadows
testimony in DC
to one of his former attorneys
pleading guilty in Georgia.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
One thing I've never been able
to understand about Trump World
is how all these guys
handle the pressure of being
in so much legal trouble
all the time.
They all have one foot
in prison.
They drink scotch like water
and eat nothing but steaks,
and somehow
they're all doing fine.
It's a real tribute to the
advances of modern cardiology.
If I let my vehicle
registration lapse for a day,
I get palpitations,
I can't feel my legs.
One time I rear ended another
car in a Costco parking lot,
got out, saw there was no damage
and just took off.
And I still have
nightmares about it.
[ Laughter ]
I just know I'm going
to be sitting on a beach
in Spain
when I'm 85 years old,
and a Chicago cop
is going to walk up behind me
and I'll say,
"What took you so long?"
[ Laughter ]
The only thing keeping
my location a secret for now
is my show airs at 12:37 in
the morning and also on Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
Take Trump, for example.
I don't know why he said,
for example.
He's "the" example.
He's got four different
criminal cases,
four examples
and a civil fraud trial.
Well, this week there have been
three major developments
in three separate
Trump cases.
His former fixer testified
against him in New York.
Another one of his lawyers
flipped on him in Georgia,
and we found out
his former chief of staff
testified to the special counsel
in DC.
-Breaking news tonight,
the former Trump
White House Chief of Staff,
Mark Meadows,
reportedly offering
damning testimony
against the former president
to special counsel Jack Smith.
-Breaking news out of New York.
Former President Donald Trump
came face to face
with his
former personal attorney
and longtime fixer,
Michael Cohen,
for the first time
in five years
inside a courtroom
in New York today,
Cohen is testifying as part
of the civil fraud case
against Trump
and his company.
-Breaking news out of Georgia,
where just this morning,
former Trump attorney
Jenna Ellis
pleaded guilty in the state's
2020 election interference case.
Ellis is now
the fourth defendant
to accept a plea deal
with prosecutors.
-When it comes
to Trump's legal troubles,
they're going to have to break
into breaking news stories,
with more breaking news.
-Breaking news tonight
the former
Trump White House
Chief of Staff...
-Breaking news out of New York.
Former President Donald Trump
came face to...
-Breaking news out of Georgia,
where just this morning,
former Trump attorney
Jenna Ellis pleaded guilt...
Breaking news
out of Sheboygan,
where Donald Trump has
just been caught shoplifting,
an Us Weekly
out of a Piggly Wiggly.
[ As Donald Trump ]
If I'm guilty of anything,
it's wanting to catch up
on the latest with Taylor
and Travis,
team...
Team both of them.
So wholesome, so sweet.
She's there with the mother,
and he supports her career.
It's just a beautiful thing.
And if there's if there's
one thing
everyone knows about Trump,
it's that I love love.
Also, I stole a bunch
of Kit-Kats
because I also love candy.
[ Normal voice ] So let's take
these one at a time.
First, there's Michael Cohen,
who testified yesterday
and again today
in a Manhattan courtroom
where Trump is at risk
of losing his business empire
in a fraud suit
brought by New York Attorney
General Letitia James.
Trump was actually
in the courtroom face
to face with Cohen,
as Cohen detailed
the various ways
in which Trump told him
to commit fraud
by lying about the value
of his company's assets.
-Former President
Donald Trump watched
as his former personal attorney,
Michael Cohen,
testified against him
in New York's lawsuit
over Trump's businesses.
-NBC News reporting this,
Cohen said,
"Trump would come up
with his own net
worth estimations."
"My responsibility,
along with Allen Weisselberg,
predominantly,
was to reverse engineer
the various
different asset classes
and increase those assets
in order to achieve a number
that Trump asked us for,"
he said.
Asked what that number would be,
Cohen said, quote,
"Whatever number he told us."
-So Trump would literally
just invent a number
for the value
of his assets
or his net worth
out of thin air.
Then tell his minions
to fudge the math
in order to make
that number work.
That would explain
why his net worth
was always some very round
clean number, like $10 billion.
No one has a net worth.
That's exactly $10 billion.
Usually there's at least
one decimal point.
It's like getting a fake ID
that says your 21st birthday
is "today."
[ Laughter ]
[ High-pitched voice ] That's
right, my birthday is today.
And that's why I need these
key-lime flavored wine coolers.
Mr. proprietor.
Ah! My fake mustache fell.
I mean, my real mustache.
[ Normal voice ] Also, how do
you get minions that loyal.
They committed crimes
for this dude.
The closest thing
I have to a minion is Wally,
and I'm pretty sure
he thinks I'm his minion.
-You're doing great, kid.
[ Laughter ]
-Also, it really helps
that Cohen has more credibility
than most of Trump's
usual goons.
Like, if Rudy Giuliani
or Mike Lindell
or Sidney Powell
testify against Trump,
it probably wouldn't even
hurt him that much,
because a jury would think
even Trump couldn't have thought
these lunatics knew anything
about voting machine technology.
Michael Cohen.
Michael Cohen
looks exactly like a dude
you would hire
for help cooking the books.
If he had a billboard,
it would say...
[ Laughter ]
And then there
was the breaking news
about Trump's former Chief
of Staff, Mark Meadows.
Meadows was there in
the White House
with Trump on January 6th,
and has reportedly
testified multiple times
in the investigation
of the coup attempt
by special counsel
Jack Smith.
-Meadows is seen
as a critical witness.
He was the White House
Chief of Staff,
and he can offer keen insights
into Trump's actions
and state of mind
following the election.
Now, he also allegedly
told investigators
that he has never seen
any evidence of fraud
that would keep now President
Joe Biden from the White House,
and that he agrees
this was the most secure
election in US history.
-Meadows also told
federal investigators
Trump was being,
"dishonest" with the public
when he first claims
to have won the election.
Hours after polls
closed on November 3, 2020,
before the final results were
in, "Obviously, we didn't win."
A source quoted Meadows
as telling Jack Smith's team
in hindsight.
-You don't get to admit
that you didn't win
now and three years later,
when you and most of your
cronies are facing jail time.
Where were you
on election night,
when Trump was scheming
with a whiskey-soaked
Rudy Giuliani to go out
and claim victory
before all the votes were in?
Or how Sidney Powell was holding
her bat [bleep] crazy press
conference,
wearing the pelt of a leopard
she claimed had rigged
the election,
along with China
and the ghost of Hugo Chavez.
[ As Sidney Powell ]
I personally killed
this leopard myself
when I found him
trying to vote
for Joe Biden in Pennsylvania.
Sorry, leopard,
but you're not 18,
and now you're never
going to be.
[ Normal voice ]
I hope the special counsel
got a lot more information
from Meadows,
because Meadows
definitely knows a lot more.
For example,
you might remember
that Meadows' aide
Cassidy Hutchinson
testified before
the January 6th Committee.
Hutchinson revealed
that as the mob
was rampaging
through the Capitol,
chanting hang Mike Pence,
Meadows confirmed that Trump
agreed with the mob.
-We have some remarkable
new accounts
of just how explicitly
Donald Trump encouraged violence
on that day
and in its wake.
One of those accounts
comes from a new book
written by the former aide
to Trump Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows,
that's Cassidy Hutchinson.
In this excerpt highlighted
by my colleague Rachel Maddow
ahead of her interview with
Cassie Hutchinson last night,
Hutchinson describes a scene
from the afternoon
of January 6th,
after news has broken
that the rioters
have breached the Capitol.
-I can't wait to hear
Trump's excuse
for yelling the word
"hang" as the mob
was on TV
ransacking the Capitol,
literally chanting
they wanted to hang Mike Pence.
[ As Donald Trump ] I wasn't
saying hang Mike Pence,
I was saying
"Hangin' with Mr. Cooper,"
My favorite...
My favorite '90s TV.
Where are my '90s kids at?
We all -- We all love
Mr. Cooper, don't we folks?
That was part of the TGIF block
on ABC.
T-GIF, as I called it,
along with "Boy Meets World"
and "Full House."
You know,
I once met Dave Coulier once.
He came up to me,
big guy, funny guy,
tears pouring down his face
and onto his tacky
brightly colored shirt.
And he said to me, he said,
"Sir, those radical,
those radical woke Democrats
need to cut it out."
[ Laughter ]
They do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was very --
He was very unkind to Alanis.
You need to know that about him?
You oughta know.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
But at the very least,
we have the president's
chief of staff
now reportedly confirming
that he knew the entire time
the election fraud stuff
was all [bleep].
And, yet, the election
deniers nonetheless
remain the core
of the current Republican Party.
That's who controls the party,
as evidenced by their selection
today of a new speaker,
a far-right conservative
who almost no one
has heard of named Mike Johnson.
I think they're hoping to bore
everyone into forgetting
how extreme he is.
Mike Johnson is the fake name
they give you
when you call tech support.
So it sounds like you're talking
to someone in Kansas
when you're definitely talking
to someone in Albania.
[ Albanian accent ]
Yes, I am Mike Johnson.
Did you try unplug
and plug in again?
[ Normal voice ]
Even his fellow Republicans
didn't know much about him.
Senator Susan Collins,
and this is true,
said she'd have to look him up.
A reporter from CNN wrote
today...
[ Laughter ]
Well, when you Google him,
you're going to need
to put in more information
than just the name Mike Johnson.
Mike Johnson
is such a common name.
Most of us went to school
with one.
My Mike Johnson
played baseball.
This Mike Johnson played
a key role
in the effort to overturn
the 2020 election results
and was, according to
The New York Times...
...on January 6th.
But Republicans desperately
do not want to talk
about that,
as evidenced by this
press conference last night
where a reporter tried
to ask Mike Fake Name
about his effort
to overturn the election,
and the group
of Republicans assembled
literally booed the reporter.
-[ Booing ]
-Next question.
-Oh, grow up!
[ Laughter ]
You're booing
like a bunch of kids
at a production
of "PAW Patrol" on ice
when Mayor Humdinger comes out.
[ As Mayor Humdinger ]
Oh, wait until I get my hands
on those pesky pups.
[ Imitates children booing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Went and saw
"PAW Patrol" two this weekend.
Woof!
[ Laughter ]
In retrospect, I should have --
I should have taken my kids.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
They wanted to see
"Killers of the Flower Moon."
[ Laughter ]
and I'm like,
"That's too long.
I'm going to go see
'PAW Patrol.'"
But then that backfires
because this is, like,
90 minutes.
I got to sit in
the [bleep] lobby.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, can you imagine
having the gall
to boo someone for asking
a simple question
after you paralyze
the government for three weeks
of spectacle
and humiliating incompetence,
where you screamed
and yelled at each other
like a bunch of street pigeons
fighting over a French fry.
You booed the reporter.
That's like going
to a football stadium
and getting booed
by the Giants.
[ Laughter ]
Do I boo you when you vape
and get too handsy
at "Beetlejuice" the musical?
No, I get an usher
like an adult.
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we zoom in
on this kindly older woman
up front to hear
what she had to say?
-Shut up!
Shut up.
That's North Carolina
Congress monster
and election denier,
Virginia Fox.
And maybe steer clear of
her house on Halloween, kids,
because I'm pretty sure
it's going to be raisins.
[ Laughter ]
And yet, even after
they spent three weeks
humiliating themselves
and breaking the government,
Republicans actually celebrated
when they finally managed
to do the single basic
aspect of their jobs,
like they had just landed
a rover on Mars.
Maybe instead
of patting themselves
on the backs
and yelling at reporters,
you guys should at least
have the decency to...
-Shut up.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]